das ist echt nicht gut
junge spaß ist wenn jedes jahr probiert
haben wollt euch der geschmeckt haben
müsse man den kommentaren weil es kann
mir vorstellen also würde ich da heute
siehst
[Musik]
da zusammen
ich habe euch jetzt gut hast du gott
macht macht nochmal das normal den
richtigen anfang etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
kirche video von mir ich musste mich
erst mal extrem entschuldigen gestern
gab es ja kein video zum mega light ich
war ein bisschen angeschlagen musste bis
nach köln von und ich habe es einfach
zeitlich nicht geschafft das video
fertig zu stellen
deswegen ist halt kein es gab ja ja
dafür gibt es heute sein umso
interessanter ist ich weiß ganz genau
dass es sehr viele von euch sehr gerne
schauen und zwar kam der letzte partner
schon vor ungefähr eineinhalb bis zwei
monaten glaube ich und zwar ist das bei
mcdonald's irgendwie cast die bringen
echt schnell immer neue produkte raus
und gleicher zeit sowieso viel mit
erstmal habe ich mir gedacht ein kommen
diese chance nutzte gefallen es
vielleicht wieder hin und testen die
neuen sachen man muss auch ganz klar
sagen ihr schicken wir mal so oft bei
elster an hengst kümmert es wieder nur
über mcdonald's testes mal und viele
schreiben auch schon dazu okay das
schmeckt gut oder schmeckt nicht gut und
deswegen würde das gerne schaut
ich hätte das gerne ich würde sagen
jetzt wir fahren los beim autor für
sagen wir gehen schon mal runter dann
könnte ich euch währenddessen mal zeigen
was da gerade neues gibt ihr dieses
regenbogen los des regenwassers haben
einmal regenbogen ist okay leute und
zwar wir haben ganz ganz viele leute
irgendwie so ein haar weitergeschickt
also was das ist keine ahnung der ist
irgendwie neu wie das aus ach so genau
das ist eine ananas zwischen davos und
ansonsten was haben wir noch neues major
super jobs mango okay da haben wir noch
irgendwie so drachenfrucht tasche die
soll extrem eklig sein weil das haben
wir doch als die leute geschrieben
anlässlich habe heute die drachenfrucht
asche getestet die wiebels täglich
probiert die macht deswegen ich bin auf
jeden fall gespannt was man aussagen
musste er youri der ist heute sogar
krank und film trotzdem dieses video
da muss man doch einfach mal
applaudieren also das kann nicht echt
richtig spitze dafür haben wir doch
schon mal direkt die filmschau mike
stewart oder 10.000 10.000 fans haben
sich eigentlich bei mcdonald's schon mal
gefragt warum du immer so komische
bestellung aufgibt wie komische ja keine
ahnung wieso 50 tiefs bürger oder nur
pommes oder nur 20 hätten also ich kenne
einen typen bei dem habe ich schon
bestimmt zehnmal extrem komische sachen
gestellt und der tut aber immer so als
würde er mich nicht kennen also ich weiß
nicht ob er das wirklich nicht ob damit
mein gesicht wirklich noch nicht kennt
oder ob der einfach so darauf den weg
gibt und was ich ja auch wirklich sagen
muss ich war schon länger nicht mehr da
also ich bin ja nur für videos deswegen
wenn ich schon dabei ist die bestellung
immer ein bisschen komisch ich mein ich
will hat auch noch was zu essen so
schlimm kann es ja nicht sein
20 hab ich mir ist habe ich auch noch
nie bestellt ich hatte auf jeden fall
schon mal 35 kommen und irgend eine
bestellung hat mal 160 euro kostet das
weiß ja auch noch was das jetzt genau
war weil sie nicht mehr kann ja auch
gleich mal sagen ja was geht ich hätte
gerne einmal alles neue
mainz das klappt manchmal besuchen
polizeidirektor es ist komisch glas ja
was am meisten davon
ich hätte gerne einmal die drachenfrucht
tasche genau dazu kommt ein mc sunday
saurer apfel eistüte shop dann einmal
diese hawaii burger florida jobs einmal
dieses regenbogen glas geht nicht ich
glaube das war's moment ich muss kurz
hus musi mango ananas in klein um das
war's
dankeschön kannst du sollen reinstellen
das wäre schon
wir haben uns zwei sachen bestellt ach
so ok danke sonntag noch als arbeiterin
oder er hat man ziemlich ich hab nicht
gekocht hat falls es nicht aber ich
wollte meinen regenbogen klären das ist
ja echt noch in einiger ringe das das
nächste mal mit mehr als richtiger wände
und decken über das wenn du nur mac
genügen würde ich hier habe die jungen
ich hab ich noch alexa gebracht das
haben willst also durch drehen ja alles
gut verheilt
das habe ich gerade noch gesehen kann
man normalerweise gibt es ja diese eis
also diese kleine eistüte oder wie man
das nennt nur in heller mit helm ein
heller waffeln und haben jetzt einfach
eine dunkle ist schon interessant auch
wie immer eigentlich also da frage ich
mich auch wieso man sowas dann einen
test was bringt das jetzt genau
eigentlich nicht viel
hallo leute wir sehen uns in fünf
minuten wenn ich zu hause bin
bis gar nicht ich freue mich aber gerade
auch dass hier neue ist weil das gab es
glaube ich schon mal aber auch nie
wieder raus wenn man jetzt ist das halt
wieder eingeführt worden scheint okay
wir sind sofort haben bin ich echt mal
gespannt ob ich das hier um haut oder
nicht wir werden natürlich wieder von 1
bis 10
[Musik]
willkommen zurück
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wir haben
insgesamt sagen gekauft wovon ich glaube
ich glaube das ist eigentlich mal das
mal kurz überprüfen kann aber auch sein
dass ich das mit rudi verwechselt ich
kann ja auch sein dass es gab noch mal
holt also alle die sich damit auskennen
steigen erst sehr gerne mal die
kommentare das hier ist ein mango ananas
eis nun die genau
ich will mir nicht sicher aber ich
glaube ihm habe ich schon mal probiert
weil er schmeckt auch nicht so nah ist
also obwohl das geht eigentlich ist auf
jeden fall vom 6
zehn punkten mehr ist nicht drin
herzlich folgen dann muss ja ganz schön
seite sind irgendwie auch seine mama
strip und zwar ist meine vermutung dass
hier ist ein ganz normaler hamburger mit
einer analyse über also dass sie
schmeckt mag ich zu bezweifeln
und dann haben wir hier jetzt noch ne
drachenfrucht tasche die von euch so
stark bemängelt wurde sollte man kurz zu
sagen wir machen leute wir sind jetzt
mal schlauer
da das eis schmilzt problem war dass man
als erstes von schneider überschlug
letztes mal neu das mc sunday ananas und
jetzt haben wir max hunger ist saurer
apfel und ich habe das mc sunday ananas
schon sehr hart kritisiert weil es mich
nicht überzeugt hat das hat irgendwie
gar nicht gepasst und ob das jetzt
besser passt mag ich zu bezweifeln
deswegen check was mal abgehoben ist
schon sehr wichtig als ich muss wirklich
sagen die kombination zwischen
vanilleeis und sauren apfel der dann gar
nicht mehr sauer schmeckt ist schon gut
dass wir gleich richtig gute leute oder
spaß hätte ich niemals gedacht immer
wenn ich mal da sein sollte dann
bestelle ich mir so ein mc sunday
karamell oder so und das hier schmeckt
mir einfach noch besser also ohne spaß
die leute die das kreiert haben dass ich
den hut vor
[Musik]
einer musste es probieren
schmeckt wirklich gut dreht von mir
unfassbare zehn von zehn punkte
schlechter geht es einfach nicht meiner
meinung nach ein geiles eis müssen stets
davon nicht schlecht dazu gesagt besser
geht s einfach schlechter geht's einfach
wasser jetzt besser geht zu entwerten
nicht weiter geht's einfach mit den
jetzt mal direkt hinterher
das mcfly chupa chup guck mal hier sind
so wahrscheinlich dass es so von levi's
mit mangos oder ob das jetzt noch besser
ist man werden sehen die anderen kinder
die von ihren eltern das hier willkommen
weitergehen auf die zähne kaputt gemacht
die beißen auf so kleines stück vom
super typ groben oder wie und das
prickelt noch extrem und also dass hier
schlecht für die zähne
deswegen gibt's leider von mir nur lieb
gemeinter fünf von zehn punkte jetzt
nicht mehr ganz gesundheitlich gesehen
wahrscheinlich er auch nicht deswegen
genau hier und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt auf diesen hatte man kann man
das ist halt alter das ist halt wirklich
ein cheeseburger
boah da frage ich mich auch wer denkt
sich das aus das kann nicht schmecken
oder die pizza wie viel hast du und wir
am morgen rauch ich würde sagen ich weiß
jetzt einfach rein und mal schauen aber
ich kann mir wirklich nicht vorstellen
das ist gut schmecken wird deswegen wir
werden sehen
das echt nicht gut
ohne spaß ist wenn jeder probiert habt
und euch der geschmeckt hat schreibt mir
dass meine kommentare weil es kann mir
vorstellen also möchte ich dass es so
edel konsistenz es tut mir leid aber ich
kann ja muss ich kann ihr keinen punkt
vergeben das kriegt nur von zehn punkte
und spaß ich habe noch nie irgendwas
gegessen von madls was mich so wenig
überzeugt hat wie das und ich war früher
schon öfter war da die firma in der
folge beenden ich bin nicht mehr öfter
da wurde spaß nur für die neuen produkte
wenn ich die testen okay dann haben wir
zum schluss sogar drachenfrucht tasche
die von euch schon in meinen instagram
gm sehr sehr schlecht dargestellt wurde
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt wer immer
auf 50 erfolgreiche wir brechen die
immer aus ja also ich schon riechen tut
die eigentlich ganz gut so danke
[Musik]
ganz schön praktisch mit dem ganzen
neuen doch im grunde haben magst du
trafen frucht so ich finde es eigentlich
auch ganz ehrlich ich probiere es doch
einmal ein bisschen weniger
drachenfrucht das mit folgen nach
zahnpasta oder so also ich muss wirklich
sagen ich mag da und ich hab dachte
früher immer so dass in der eisdiele
aber hier muss ich sagen das schmeckt
ihnen mit ziemlich hämisch deswegen hat
mich einfach nicht haben ist sollte ich
ganz so schlimm wie dieser hawaii bürger
aber hier gibt es von mir leider auch
nur zwei von zehn punkte nehmen wir das
nicht übel das einzige was mich
umgehauen hat war dieses max handel
saurer apfel eis also das richtig gut
zehn prozentpunkte auf vorlage gegeben
das wars mit dem heutigen test schreibt
mir weitere ideen für erstens videos
oder auch andere videos in die
kommentare
jeden abend 19 uhr gibt es ein neues
video auf diesem kanal dienstag knapp 30
alex wie und wir sehen uns morgen um 19
uhr aus rein